avec nous ce soir fait d'éprouver le pdg
d'aéroports de montréal bonsoir monsieur
rainville au chaud chaud
cette station là c'est la seule des 26
stations du rem qui fait pas partie de
l'entente de financement entre la caisse
de dépôt et ses partenaires c'est vous
qui devez la financer est ce que c'est
une erreur ça non c'est tout à fait
prévu ça fait parti d'un apport de fonds
n'avait avec la caisse des dépôts à 2016
quand on s'est assis pour regarder
évidemment le train si durable y
venaient à l'aéroport il faut comprendre
que c'est au port de lorient s'apprête à
faire migrer
j'ai arrêté parce que c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué s'apprête à faire la méga
procès de 2.5 milliards de dollars à
laquelle on réaménage examen tous les
débarcadères et le rem se trouvait
évidemment à plein coeur de nos travaux
pour comprendre que c'est un monument
s'exécuter pendant qu'on opère donc on y
viendra des passagers parfois c'est ces
travaux majeurs donc au moment où on
avait jugé opportun on devait s'en
occuper lui même
yves demain pour avoir une logistique et
me dire la fluidité avec les pages on
est passager et là votre projet
totalisant 2 milliards et demi et ce qui
lie remis en question il est interdit
c'est certain et et on reproche souvent
des infrastructures sont vieillissantes
un accès il va falloir fermer et c'est
clair que ça aussi c'est la théorie
il vous demandez quoi aujourd'hui au
gouvernement à faire don à plaissan
important ainsi en fait on est on n'a
pas de revenus 1 le trafic ici est
littéralement arrêté donc on n'a aucun
revenu donc à l'échelon avait prévu pour
faire le projet de m cette année on
élève est mis de côté il arracha husky
donc c était bien là c'est forlan ne
sont pas disponibles
on essaie venise au minage pas de notre
de notre entente avec le cdbq de faire
la station toutefois on a besoin d'un
peu de temps non jeu qu'on a besoin
c'est de rire sans intérêt sans
remboursement de capital jusqu'à ce que
notre trafic revient à la normale de
500-600 millions ces salles près en
étant très jeune et jolie dame ne sera
pas réparé 5 6 1 millions shaybah est ce
qu'il ya d'autres investisseurs ou
d'autres solutions de financement où
vous êtes rendu et a demandé aux deux
paliers de gouvernement
vous a aidé il ya toujours quelqu'un
vous lui prêtez de l'argent ça c'est
certain mais écoutez on veut pas attirer
non plus à nos finances a pu t on au
final deux sont retrouvés important
parce que dès que la reprise arrive et
il y aura la même affaire mais il y aura
aussi d'autres investissements à faire
jose pour suivre le flot de l'évolution
des technologies dans le secteur et des
investissements majeurs
on va vouloir aussi poursuivre le reste
de notre projet d'accès à l'aéroport
pearson
donc il faut quand même que c'est les
taux d'intérêt qu'on va payer et il le
ferait qu'on a un intérêt il devait pour
cette courte période là il faut que ce
soit réservé juste pour être bien clair
est-ce qu'il est possible que cette
citation dur et aiment ne voit pas le
jour
si nautique adm et nous finale ces six
autres fois solution c'est clair il ya
la protestation au bout du tunnel et
dans quelques semaines au bout de la
piste derrière moi il ya un site celui
qui va après la seule et qui va peser
jean l ibis à venir jusqu'au terminal
les livres ont frappé un mur parce
qu'avant pas de garçon n'a pas les
moyens de le faire et c'est pour ça
qu'on fait c'est pourquoi on les blâmer
jeu pour dicter avec le tunnelier
entente est il qu'on doit de démarrer
les travaux sur le pont d'un financement
la place et comme je le dis on se
désengage paru faire le projet mais on
est bon en 2009 l'aéroport a accueilli
20 millions de passagers la tendance est
très bonne et à la hausse depuis une
quinzaine d'années l'on comprend que
c'est un mur là 2020 c'est quoi vos
perspectives selon vous à partir de
maintenant
merci de préciser parce que l'aéroport
de montréal avait le vent dans lyzel
littéralement on avait une performance
exceptionnelle
on est devenus depuis revenue depuis
v14 un des principaux avocats nada à nos
perspectives pour les ans on avait prévu
une croissance pour les 15 prochaines
années il est aujourd'hui hauts et des
bas dans la tête sheetrit mais jamais
comme on a vécu là donc pour cette année
2010 on s'attend à peu près rien on
n'est pas trafiquant ce moment une
reprise graduelle en rivière et un
retour à la normale
espérons le réveil si la fin 22 donc
les aéroports du canada contrairement à
certains aéroports dans le monde ne
reçoivent pas des subventions
directement du gouvernement c'est plus
l'utilisateur payeur vous êtes aussi un
organisme sans but lucratif donc financé
par les voyageurs par les compagnies
aériennes
est-ce qu'on pourrait changer ça s quel
modèle doit changer le modèle 2 janvier
servir jusqu'à présent et que tu es mon
père et qu'on traverse une petite heure
de crise notre cas de crise y est
excellente et pas comme excellents et
cécile halak rythme perdu entre l'otan
et restent dans l'état que je vous ai
décrit plutôt le modèle capable de son
yves de structure il ya une lettre qui a
été publié ce que je demande c'est la
page du globe et de mer le ce matin
demande publique faite par air canada
par westjet apport que par la banque
royale par le cn par telus par bce même
le canadien de montréal là dedans qui
demande de rouvrir le transport aérien
canadien est ce que vous appuyez ça et
puis il faut quand même s'il demande à
lotir des frontières mais de façon
prudente de façon tactique là où c'est
possible de le faire donc ils sont eux
aussi très prudent
tout le monde est soucieux de la santé
des passagers et dans ce contexte là
évidemment oui nous appuyons la démarche
des compagnies aériennes nous sommes
dans la même édition nous avons les
mêmes enjeux il nous croyons qu'il ya
une possibilité ya des et des façons de
ré ouvrir progressivement le trafic sur
certaines destinations internationales
je l'aimé
monsieur rainville merci pour cet
entretien ce soir merci beaucoup
bonsoir